so one hour in three no I'm falling
behind they gots a really [ __ ] start
learning that but foods coming back and
the mackerel is salty which is a common
thread across we know we're going to
pick up the speed
pick up the gear pick up the standards
you know but this will get better on to
the mains and near there's this plan is
not the diner socks off with the
wonderful flavors of a Fino classic
belly of pork with red wine sauce
now that port looks fantastic no Bess
she's also cooking an amazing wild sea
bass with squid wrapped and smoked
pancetta it's almost perfect but with
little else but fish on the plate I
worried lacked balance and need some
garnish well they dot yes we thought
they but this is the menu I know we
don't have them in the menu nervous what
I'm trying to do to make her happy she
wants potatoes can we do it yes if we
can do them chef please
I think I'll sort out as a situation
okay my one concern with the bass was no
starch on there the rich sauce the squid
it needs are stuck Joe I need something
along those lines but we can pull the
taters it takes six or seven minutes and
let the weight be no doing everything
they can to please their customers great
that gives three centers one big fish
these are like the most delicious potato
me and on to basketball court you said
two minutes two minutes ago
there'd be about four minutes chef five
minutes let's see what I've got any
other it doesn't I can go from the other
man back in the kitchen
John rain Peter also serving pork but a
mixing belly with prime cut Phillip top
of the Italian garnishes service cost me
up
my sweet the boys are also creating a
fantastic Italian sea bass with
cannellini beans I love it because it's
so simple
no wild avant-garde frills for this dish
I had the sea bass from my main course
this game was crispy this the fish was
cooked perfectly
Table one main course back said that was
the best piece of fish she's ever had in
her life free no finishing with a
classic Spanish dessert Santiago tart
could this poplar sweet be their winning
touch
the favors of the album creatively
avatar ladies is me again they're
good-looking one for their dessert
John rain Peter are serving a modern
Italian take on apple crumble with
almond infuse custard but they've added
a twist that's leaving some of my diners
confused the apples melon like lukewarm
but the rest of it is very cold just not
sure slightly warm because it too hot
the flavor can be affected okay
kazimierz apple crumble is meant to be
eaten warm but is leaving some customers
cold it was been saddled I'm afraid the
rest of the meal was amazing the dessert
let it down a little bit
10:00 p.m. and service is over tonight
the diner's decided how much to pay they
loved both restaurants so the takings
were equal but this challenge wasn't
simply about money
well done my chef